men don't care about IQ I really
strongly disagree with that because look
you don't want a low intelligence Woman
as a life partner sharing a house with
who's incapable of understanding
finances who doesn't succeed in her
career who's not a smart devoted mom to
your kids who's socially embarrassing I
think humor is more of a factor I guess
in mate selection than height look try
rationally to focus on out of the traits
I think I want which of them actually
matter in the modern world
[Music]
Jeffrey Miller welcome to my podcast
great to be here really excited yeah
this should be a very interesting
conversation
I have a bunch of questions mostly about
men and women but before we get started
can you give a brief background about
who you are and what it is you do I'm an
evolutionary psychology Professor so I
study human nature and I work at
University of New Mexico
um I did a ba at Columbia my PhD at
Stanford I worked in England for 10
years and lots of other places and I've
mostly studied
human sexuality and mate choice and how
we fall in love and what traits we've
fallen in love with and then more
recently I've gotten a lot more engaged
in kind of political Twitter and a
movement called effective altruism and
I'm currently working on
um how to make artificial intelligence
behave better with with humans
wow okay that's cool well that's okay
I'm gonna add a couple questions in
there then Ai and then you said
effective altruism yeah the EA Movement
we can talk about that too if you want
yeah no I definitely do
effective altruism okay cool wow well I
just have a whole bunch of questions to
throw at you
um about sexuality I think and Dynamics
between men and women so first off this
is something I've been wondering for a
while
um do do females compete with each other
because we know men compete with each
other to get women do females compete
with each other oh yeah very much so I
mean the methods of what we call female
versus female competition a very
technical term
um one thing I love about evolution of
biology is actually the technical terms
are pretty intuitive and pretty easy to
understand
um like my time my colleague Tonya
Reynolds here at University of New
Mexico specializes in in studying female
female competition now the typical forms
that that takes tend to be more verbal
and reputational rather than direct
violent conflict okay so women might
derogate each other behind each other's
backs they might
um try to manipulate each other's
self-esteem if they feel like the sexual
Rivals competing for the same guys or
for the same social status so it's not
like you know
women getting into prehistoric MMA
fights that much it's more about using
um the weapons of uh verbal creativity
and theory of mind and and social
sensitivity
to just get
subtle but sustained advantages over
your female rivals
so high school basically yeah high
school but forever and in prehistory
oh that's terrible that's terrible it
does seem to get at least I know that my
relationship with other women has gotten
a lot better since high school so does
is that because the competition tones
down or is that because we're all stuck
together in a classroom uh or or do
people get smarter and sneakier what
happens there I think yeah good insights
I think it's a combination of all of
that smarter and sneakier so you're
using less obvious competitive tactics
so
um for example one thing that can happen
is
women can be in a Friendship Circle
and you want to sort of derogate or
ostracize or marginalize one particular
woman in the group so she has lower
status
instead of women saying okay Jane over
there she's a bad person we should avoid
her
you could say something like you know
I'm really worried about Jane because it
just seems like she's um
he has really bad taste in men and she's
you know I'm worried about her drinking
you know whatever and so
there will be the the implanting of
negative information
about some rival within her friend group
or her colleagues or co-workers
and then the other women will will think
oh well this person derogating her is
expressing what sounds like genuine
empathic interest like they're concerned
about Jane's drinking and and her being
too and stealing other men or
whatever right
but the information itself is enough
to lead other women to kind of
marginalize that that Target if you guys
haven't heard I have launched a
nootropics company called smart drugs
which was immediately banned by
MailChimp because of the use of the word
drugs but anyway we're going to be
coming out with a bunch of new products
but our first one is
after party
it's not just for partying though people
seem to hate the name because they're
like I don't party I just drink two
glasses of wine before I go to bed
you're partying I know anyway this is
about to sell out because covid and the
government ruined the world so it's
going to take four months for me to
restock so if you want to try it try it
now I've been using this for literally
10 years to avoid hangovers sourcing the
main ingredient dihydramy ricotine
online since I was 20. dad and some of
his friends came to Miami in the last
month to film at Peterson Academy and
some of his friends were drinking he
doesn't but they do and I brought in a
bottle of after party and one of his
friends was like this is somebody I'd
known since I was a kid was like Mick
you showed me this 10 years ago and I
literally travel with it without you I
would be drinking much less bourbon
which is not the goal of this pill at
all it does work though it helps break
down the toxic byproduct of alcohol
acetaldehyde
acetaldehyde is what damages you so
badly when drinking check it out and the
study showing how it works at
smartdrugs.life there's a lot of nerd
stuff on there I worked hard on the
website broke down some scientific
studies code MP for 15 off hopefully you
like it and if you don't there's a 30
day money back guarantee no questions
asked so if you don't like it no worries
I just want you to give it a shot
because
it works to make you not feel awful
after drinking even if it's just a
couple of glasses of wine your body can
use help breaking down acetaldehyde so
try it out smartdrugs.life code MP
hope you enjoy it enjoy the rest of this
episode have have you done work on
personality like because I know that
there are some women who are really good
at that and that's what they do and I
feel like some people are less
interested in that is that from
personality differences yeah I'm a big
one I'm a big fan of the Big Five
personality traits system and I've I've
often used it in my research it's a man
it's a great thing to measure when in
doubt if you're running a psych study
try to get some measure of General
cognitive ability or intelligence if you
can and try to measure the big five
because they're almost always predictive
in this particular case female versus
female competition
um it'll probably be a combination of
low agreeableness
which is kind of associated with you
know assertiveness and a little
machiavellianism and manipulativeness
um there will be a little bit of
extroversion mixed in in terms of being
socially assertive enough
to try to manipulate other people rather
than just kind of withdrawn and
introverted
um
and I think it also takes
maybe a relatively High degree of
emotional stability
or low neuroticism
to do these tactics right because they
can't they're risky and they can
backfire
so if a woman's very
um
neurotic worried anxious depressed she's
not as likely I think to use these kinds
of uh tactics
but that's pretty speculative it's
pretty speculative but that's where I'd
put it back
okay I hope it's speculative you've just
described
exactly my personality almost actually
not not entirely no the agreeableness my
my do you have you ever split it up into
like sub domains so grievalness splits
into yeah yeah the facets sorry
um I scored almost zero in politeness
but compassion was like 89. so I guess
that doesn't make me like unreasonably
disagreeable on average
yeah I think those so the the facet
level traits are really important
because a lot of people are kind of
vaguely heard of the big five like from
you or from Jordan Peterson or or
whoever but each of them has these
sub-components right just like
intelligence has components like spatial
intelligence verbal intelligence
uh social intelligence
any given Big Five trait like
agreeableness will have these little
components like compassion politeness
I'm I'm kind of like you like
online on Twitter I'm not super polite
in person I'm highly polite and I I like
to think I'm pretty compassionate in
terms of like actually caring about
people and animals and so forth
yeah interesting okay
very cool uh well I guess we might as
well talk about what effective altruism
is
this is a movement launched about 10 or
12 years ago by a couple of Oxford moral
philosophers will mcgaskill and Toby ORD
and it's grown into this kind of global
movement of tens of thousands of people
mostly young people
mostly highly compassionate maybe a
little bit aspergery on average like
um highly rational highly systematizing
people
and the concept is try to do the most
good that you can in the world but using
reason and evidence and open-minded kind
of rational debate rather than just
virtue signaling or rather than just
going with your your gut feeling or your
empathy
right so
what the effect of altruists tended to
talk about a lot is
look if you're going to give to charity
um try to find Charities that actually
have
good empirical evidence
that what they're spending money on
actually does some good actually works
so they like recommending Charities that
have actually run like randomized
clinical trials
for their interventions
so for example one thing that really
seems to help to reduce Global poverty
is a thing called Direct Cash transfers
so there's an organization called give
directly where you can donate money to
them and they'll simply like wire the
money to poor people who could use it
and who have the wisdom to spend it on
whatever they think they need
instead of us telling them what we think
they need
and randomized controlled trials show
that's actually very effective at
reducing poverty and improving lives
um so the basic idea is you try to have
kind of a scientific mindset
rather than just a virtue signaling
mindset when you're doing
beneficence when you're trying to do
good in the world
and I've taught several courses on the
psychology of effective altruism
and some of the ways that our kind of
intuitive moral psychology
fits with that viewpoint but also really
struggles with it
because I think a lot of our moral
intuitions
basically come from
hundreds of thousands of years of virtue
signaling
right to get
credibility at an ethical level within
our little Clan or tribe and we're not
very well adapted
to thinking about large-scale problems
like effect eight billion people in the
world or that affect maybe billions or
trillions of animals
um so EA is is basically an attempt to
like
fill the gap between our
evolved moral intuitions versus what
actually works in the modern world
I hope that makes some some sense that
definitely makes it a pretty weird
movement but I I think it's exciting
well it sounds like intelligent people
trying to do good that sounds good yeah
that sounds good to me
um so you said we've like we've all
evolved through virtue signaling in kind
of smaller groups of people and tribes
do you think that goes for kind of
everybody back then across the board
because I always assumed virtue
signaling was well basically lying yeah
I have more of a kind of neutral take
like I I published this little book
called virtue signaling in 2019 and I
tried to emphasize like
virtue signaling as a term became very
common around 2016 with the Trump versus
Clinton election and it was often used
by conservatives to make fun of leftist
people
preaching at everybody but not actually
doing very much good
right so there's a negative kind of uh
cheap talk
version of virtue signaling where you're
just running around on social media
saying you guys should do this don't do
that you're good you're bad blah blah
um my view is virtue signaling can be
extremely positive for example
if uh you got two single people and
they're searching for mates and they
meet up and they have a date
they're trying to evaluate each other's
kind of ethical compass and their
personality traits like how agreeable
how compassionate is this person
and they'll talk about all kinds of
things that basically boil down to
Virtue signals
but some of those might actually be
reliable indicators right so if they say
look I've I volunteer in a soup kitchen
six hours a week
it's hard to do that if you're a
psychopath right somebody with no
empathy couldn't stand to do that week
after week
so it is actually
um
some kind of good signal of underlying
values and personality traits
I just wish that more people
were selective about what they actually
do
and maybe do things that deliver
real benefits to others rather than just
working as really good signals of Who
You Are
well said thanks okay yeah yeah
um slightly changing topics then why
what's the evolutionary benefit of
psychopathy why is that still around
there's a lot of discussion about this
and there are I think very good insights
going all the way back to the 1980s
right people have been discussing this
if
humans evolved in small Clans and tribes
where you know everybody and you gather
huge amounts of social information about
people you interact with regularly
you might think
there's just no room to be a psychopath
if you're regularly exploiting deceiving
manipulating people aren't people going
to find out and push you out of the clan
and that's basically a death sentence
right Exile equals Death
if you're in a prehistoric situation
where you cannot survive by yourself out
in the wilderness
well my personal hunch actually
is that the rates of psychopathy
in small hunter-gatherer societies are
quite low
I think it's correct you can't survive
as a psychopath in a small
plan where everybody knows you
however
once you get civilization and
Agriculture and city-states and big
populations and you can move from group
to group
sequentially uh then suddenly there's a
niche there's a niche for the psychopath
so my hunch actually is psychopathy
sociopathy more generally might be a
fairly recent development and just kind
of post-civilization development
um if you look at like the American West
like my ancestors were roaming around in
the 1800s and you could
you know if your reputation was
shattered in one place
you could move to a new town adopt a new
identity build up a new reputation get
people to trust you
um
and it it can work and
um you know nowadays psychopathy seems
to positively predict
like number of babies especially for men
ah yeah okay that makes sense because
it's associated with sexually
exploitative tactics with seduction
manipulation
um
not just like physical sexual coercion
but also
you know I've been a little bit
peripherally involved in the pickup
artist movement for like 15 years and
I've talked to the poas and I know some
of them
and it's a weird movement because there
are a significant number of like actual
hardcore psychopaths in it
we're trying to figure out
okay how do I you know seduce manipulate
deceived women
and then there's a bunch of normies and
normal people with normal Personalities
in it who legitimately just are confused
by modern dating and want to learn good
honorable
you know methods for finding a
girlfriend
but there's certainly a niche for the
psychopaths in the modern dating Market
that's very interesting do you think
social media too has like increased I
guess how
how often you see Psychopaths because I
feel like if you're an extroverted
person and you're disagreeable oh
actually but before we get into like
that question can you describe what
personality traits compose a psychopath
I mean the usual ways of recognizing
like a hardcore kind of criminal
psychopath as opposed to like a
white-collar sociopath okay hardcore
criminal psychopath would be
lack of empathy lack of remorse
um they're uh very comfortable lying if
you catch them out in a lie they're not
embarrassed they just keep lying some
more to cover it up they defend to have
an unstable lifestyle they move
locations they move jobs a lot they have
um
a kind of complicated checkered sexual
history with lots of ex-girlfriends
don't want to talk about why why the
breakups happened
um
they tend to be impulsive sensation
seeking drink a lot do a lot of drugs
drive fast often have a criminal record
um
and so uh you know if you're a woman and
you're kind of on the lookout
for you really want to avoid avoid legit
bad guys
I highly recommend reading a couple
books about Psychopaths so you can know
these
um these traits and kind of recognize
them when you see them
what about conscientiousness is that
what plays a role in guilt
yeah totally do you think um I think
conscientiousness is is
associated with self-control and forward
planning and and willpower and resisting
temptation but also I think in a social
context
susceptibility to guilt and shame is
part of conscientiousness right like
when I was planning this podcast it's
like okay I'm going to put it in my
Google Calendar make sure I'm there on
time
feeling anticipatory like guilt and
shame if I fail to show up you know
that's conscientiousness
and uh the Psychopaths tend not to have
a whole lot of that like they'll just
flake out on things and not care and not
feel bad about it
wow
I know that that's not good it sounds
kind of relaxing though but I don't know
how far you'd get in life without
destroying all of your relationships and
maybe being miserable but yeah it's it's
it's an easy way to live until you end
up in federal prison and then it's not
so great
yeah okay what about um white collared
sociopaths what do they look like
um
blue collared well you didn't correct me
but did I do that wrong so white collar
blue color white collar sociopaths who
um
don't typically get involved in violent
fights and they don't typically end up
in jail but
they're willing to do the lying
deceiving manipulating in order to get
higher status wealth and prestige so you
might expect them to end up in
professions like sales marketing
politics
um
running crypto exchanges that don't
actually have the crypto that they
promise to have
Etc
and then
um
I know some forensic accountants who
work on uh white-collar crime and
figuring out what actually happened in
this company where did it go wrong
and they say there's also something
called a pink collar psychopath which is
they start out White Collar
right they're not violent but
if they get audited
if there's a legit threat that could
destroy their career then they can
actually turn violent
and get some blood on the White Collar
right so that's the pink collar
so Auditors uh people who do taxes
um white-collar crime investigators they
do have to be a little cautious
that just because somebody has an MBA
um doesn't mean they're never going to
turn violent if you're you're
probing deeply into the finances of
their
their Shady startup company
yeah
yeah fair enough I bet you could get
some people who weren't even really on
the sociopathic spectrum and still if
they do something wrong and then get
probed into can turn violent yeah
totally
and you know there's there's certain
kinds of professions and and social
situations that can kind of nudge people
either in the compassionate direction or
the kind of sociopathic Direction Just
because the Norms in their profession
so think about if you go to med school
to become a surgeon right you actually
have to become a bit of a situational
sociopath to do surgery at all
because we have most of us having a
native version to like
cutting into people and messing with
their organs
so thank God that humans can
suppress that kind of compassion under
certain circumstances where it's
adaptive to do that
why did lying develop is that an
evolutionary tool like why is it that I
mean I guess we just talked about
psychopathy a little bit in socio
sociopathy but why is it that some
people lie so much that tells stories
constantly can that be
um due to you know childhood issues and
cannot develop because of that or why
why do some people tell stories
constantly
ah
I think you know if you ask like
take a step back and ask why did
language evolve in the first place like
why can we communicate complex thoughts
and feelings to each other in a way that
no other animal species can do with as
much finesse
um people like Richard Dawkins have
argued
complex
animal communication like human language
did not evolve to convey truth
it did not evolve to reach some group
consensus about how the world is it
evolved to influence or manipulate other
animals or people
to do things in your interest
okay
so the classic example of animal
communication is
a male trying to seduce a female animal
right displaying some big courtship
plumage or like a bird song a whale song
um
a given call whatever
and the point is not to convey reliable
information about the state of the world
right the point is to convey information
about I'm a cool guy I have good genes
my brain works well mate with me and
you'll have good babies okay so that's
the the foundation of a lot of animal
communication
then when it comes to humans
you know a lot of Chit Chat that we do
is sort of
subtle bragging
or it's entertaining other people so
that they will kind of reward us with
more
status or Prestige or mating
opportunities or or jobs or or whatever
so if you take that animal communication
view of human language
then
um lying but also
kind of humor and telling benign
fictions like stories and myths and
entertainment right that should come as
no surprise
um it's only if you have this model of
language that's that says language
should work
like two objective
computer is communicating with each
other to do like a a hard to hack bank
transfer right that's a wrong model of
language
um
so like I've got a 10 month old baby
daughter and I see her just learning
you know the beginnings of babbling and
she can say mama and dada and so forth
and
she will use those tools
to the best of her ability to kind of
manipulate us to get stuff she wants
right attention food
um
playing with certain toy
and so as soon as communication
capacities develop there's we start to
use them to influence other people and I
think you know that's fine it's just
there's good ways to try to influence
other people
and then there's
super deceptive manipulative ways to do
it that don't actually yield like mutual
benefits at all
congratulations thanks
you've got our daughter too right that's
cool yeah yeah she's five
congratulations
thank you hey guys this episode was
sponsored by rabbit air as someone who's
allergic to everything I've been using
air purifiers for years I love rapid air
I have their rabbit air A3 air purifier
with my lion logo on it it looks good I
think it looks good it removes odors too
not just allergens if you have a pet you
should also get an air purifier if you
have allergies or asthma they are
massively beneficial for removing
allergens and dust from your environment
if you had mold issues not only do air
purifiers effectively remove unwanted
bits of things from the air that can
provoke an immune response but it also
looks great this is fun too rapid era
has their new artist series so you can
get cool designs on your air purifier
Vincent Van Gogh's starry night you can
put that on your air purifier that's fun
they offer a five-year warranty free
shipping and return to any 90-day
money-back guarantee on all their
products check out rabbit Air's new
artist series now visit rabbitair.com
today that's
r-a-b-b-i-t-a-i-r.com enjoy this episode
okay okay
I want to talk so you said you kind of
you're worked with or new people in the
pickup artist
group like whatever that is
um are there tactics you could tell men
that aren't sociopathic but can work to
help them get women
yeah so Tucker Max and I did a whole
book on this called uh the hardback was
called mate the paperback was called
what women want and this came out 2015
2016.
we took a very different approach we
were kind of reacting against pickup
artist culture a little bit
um
the strategy we took is to try to help
young single men
understand what women want what traits
and skills they're looking for
and then to try to convince young men
actually
there aren't really very good
like cheat codes the the way to attract
a good girlfriend is actually become a
better man and build the traits that are
legit attractive
and so the whole book was basically
about
like if you just allocate a little bit
of time and energy you can actually get
dramatic improvements in many of these
traits like it's not actually that hard
to get in better physical shape
whatever your body type whatever your
height like you can build muscle you can
lose fat you can get more energy here's
how to do it right and we talked about
everything from kettlebells to jiu jitsu
and so forth
or if you want to improve your mental
health
be less depressed and anxious and and
and introverted and scared like there's
reliably effective ways to do that also
and you're like your dad has talked
about some of these
get enough sleep eat right so your blood
sugar is not going up and down all the
time
um do your exercise meditate be mindful
blah blah
and then there's a bunch of other traits
that matter to women sense of humor you
can work on that you know a lot of young
men
will devote like 10 times as much effort
to studying for one particular class in
college
as they'll devote to building their
their active sense of humor
um like taking an improv comedy class or
whatever
so or that works
you can improve that I figured some
people are just I don't know that you
had to develop it like below the age of
10 or something I don't know what I was
thinking but that
that some people are naturally so funny
and some people aren't but there are
ways to fix that
yeah I mean
look I'm a pretty hardcore hereditarian
about a lot of things and I think you
know Evolution and genes are really
really important but
we have these big brains
in order to be able to learn useful
skills and I think
um just a lot of young men are are like
misallocating
their learning time
it's like getting really good at Call of
Duty or
um Elder ring or some video game
and they could like take the hundreds of
hours that they're doing that
and allocate it to stuff that like women
actually care about
and and and improve it dramatically it's
just like the existing educational
system isn't really geared up to
um encourage young men or young women to
do that kind of thing
yeah that's for sure
so what kind of traits I mean you named
a few but what kind of traits are women
attracted to we talk a lot about
confidence
and that
um
you know unless you're a psychopath
confidence confidence is actually pretty
hard to fake
like if a young man is getting reliable
cues that they are respected and valued
by other people
by other men by other women by their
mentors by their their classmates
confidence naturally comes from that
if you're not getting those cues that
people value and support you
it's really hard to
take it until you make it it's really
hard to sort of fake that kind of
confidence
so
there again our our Council to young man
is like find groups
where you are valued
and you do get along with people
and you've got your your little Posse
your little Friendship Circle
and try to get your confidence from
there to start
also as you build up more sexual
experience and you date more and you
just interact more with women and get
more comfortable with women
that also builds kind of sexual and
romantic confidence
which again is very hard to fake
a lot of young men have this experience
right that
no women pay attention to them
for a long time until they get a
girlfriend
they get a girlfriend suddenly they're
getting sexual validation romantic
validation and suddenly other women are
paying attention to them
and they don't even know what changed
but
um in biology that's called mate Choice
copying when females are more attracted
to a male that's valued by other females
right
and I think that's kind of mediated by
sexual self-confidence
that if if a man has a girlfriend
already
he knows at least at least there's one
woman out there who values me
and he kind of internalizes that
validation
and then like radiates it outwards
somehow in body language or how he
carries himself and then other women pay
attention to that
oh that's interesting so you think women
would be more attracted to a man in a
relationship even if they didn't know
that they were in a relationship yeah
yeah
I think so that's cool I haven't heard
that before that's cool
I don't know if there's any good
like empirical psychology research on
that but I'd be extremely surprised if
that didn't
happen and like there's so many
anecdotal reports from guys talking
about this
that like there's long dry spells nobody
wants me and then when it rains it pours
get a girlfriend and suddenly everybody
else wants me yeah
interesting okay well I like that theory
uh okay do do you think humans are
naturally monogamous do you think some
are naturally polygamous
the the line I take on this is I do
think uh humans evolve to form long-term
pair bonds
um I think that's pretty clear I think
look like five million years ago our
ancestors had huge
um sex differences and body size the
males were about twice as big and heavy
and strong as the females right oh wow
and that is what you see when there's a
highly polygamous system meaning the top
few males to mate with most of the women
and then most of the males don't get any
mates
so you get intense competition between
the males to be big strong aggressive
dominant right and to sort of monopolize
the females but then what happens is
um the males evolve to be a little
taller and a little stronger but the
females start to catch up
right females rapidly increase and so
now
although it seems like males are much
bigger and stronger than females we're
actually
about as evenly matched in body size
as
any primate as any mammal gets
that's an indicator of their bonding
that's an indicator that
males and females were were you know
matching up that they were forming
long-term relationships that were at
least
um socially monogamous which means to
hang out together live together sleep
together raise kids together
um share a lot of food with each other
share care and and compassion with each
other and so forth
so I think pair bonding is pretty
Central
to human evolution
and it's what allowed
uh things like the evolution of
fatherhood
right if you look at most mammal species
the dads the dads don't do anything the
dads just contribute genes they don't
help raise kids they don't teach kids
anything they don't even protect kids
that well
but with humans males have evolved to do
all of that
um
now that still leaves some room
for like high status High Prestige males
to sort of go outside the parabond
right and to attract additional women
and in most
complex societies that the highest
ranked wealthiest males do have multiple
wives or concubines or Mistresses or
whatever
so there's a kind of
complicated system of like
High status male
um polygamy
on top of most people forming pair bonds
um
plus some women
um also being kind of
getting resources from multiple males
like sex workers prostitutes Etc
so
are we naturally monogamous it's
complicated but like
I do think pair bonds are pretty pretty
Central to Human Experience and
particularly
um I would bet
that most babies that are that have been
born over the last few million years
have been raised by pair-bonded parents
okay that answers that question
um do do you think because you hear
about this or I've heard about this that
men and probably from kind of the red
pilled community that men don't care
about IQ
and I think even from my dad I haven't
heard men don't care about IQ but I've
heard that the reason IQ developed was
because of female mate choice
what do you think
I really strongly disagree with that
view
um when I wrote my first book The Mating
mind way back in uh 2000
I said look if if it was the case that
women care about male intelligence
but men don't care about female
intelligence you'd get a huge sex
difference in intelligence
right males would be a lot higher on IQ
than females if females were drive but
wouldn't driving it well
wouldn't the jeans like wouldn't if you
have a smart dad then wouldn't the
daughters inherit that anyway so then
right yeah I do talk about that but
brains have costs right big metabolic
costs to to grow a big brain and run it
and think and and
talk and all that so if the benefits of
having the big brain were much more
limited in women than they were in men
you know women wouldn't bother just like
women don't bother uh growing big upper
body muscles for competition
um
but in fact if you look at intelligence
research
um it seems like the Sexes are extremely
close in terms of general intelligence
like either there's no sex difference or
it's very very minimal
and some Sexes are better at some things
than than than the other but it's pretty
even
so I think what's going on
is when men are looking for short-term
made like an opportunistic
copulation like a hookup
then of course they're not going to care
opportunistic copulation
biology never using I'm never using the
word yeah I'm never using the word
hookup again opportunistic population
okay anyway continue then yeah you don't
care about the woman's intelligence
because if it's just about like the guy
getting a notch on his belt what does it
matter how smart she is
however there's good evidence
that when men are getting more serious
about choosing a long-term maid like who
do I want to live with who do I want to
marry
men get much more selective about
intelligence than they are for hookups
right why because look you don't want
a low intelligence Woman as a life
partner
sharing a house with who's incapable of
understanding finances who who doesn't
succeed in her career who's not a smart
devoted mom to your kids
who's socially embarrassing if you're
like trying to be a power couple in your
local environment
so
uh
and and we see this in the data on a
sort of debating like people of uh when
people pair up they tend to match with
someone with similar IQ
and that's typically a result of both
the men and the women being pretty
choosy about intelligence
so for women out there who go yeah but
I've gone on a bunch of First Dates the
men talk a lot they don't take any
interest in me they don't seem to care
whether I'm smart or dumb they they
don't probe like what do I know about
the world
yeah but that's a first date
let the relationship develop
what might often happen is after three
months six months two years
if you're wondering why
why hasn't he proposed to me why hasn't
he taken this to the next level
well that's where the men are getting
choosy
right that's where the men are now
evaluating not just physical
attractiveness but the woman's
intelligence and character
and the way that men get choosy
right is
they fail to escalate the commitment
right that's how they reject one huh
oh so they'll just stay in it they'll
just stay in it without moving in with
you without proposing
Etc
because look if you're um if you're a
guy and you've got a girlfriend and
you're happy and you're having sex
together
like why would you suddenly just give
that up for no reason
right if you're if you're happy in the
relationship
but she's just not quite
smart enough or stable enough or
promising enough to marry
then you'll just kind of drift along
indefinitely
right
and that's that's often sadly what what
male mate Choice looks like
huh and women don't do that right if
they they'll they'll break it off faster
I think and is that because of like
child rearing been bearing age yeah
because women's time is much more
limited in terms of fertility so the men
can kind of drift along and if if a
guy's like uh yeah I had this girlfriend
we got together I was 25 and we broke up
when I was 32 no big deal I'm still
going to be fertile for another 30 or 40
years
but for the woman
right he's he's burned through like
seven years of her precious fertility
window
and so women women ain't got time for
that they're gonna probably break it off
earlier if they think he's not
he's not the best hair upon me
and they should yeah absolutely probably
yeah because a huge risk to them
okay
um what what body parts do you think are
women attracted to like what we don't
have to just say body parts but like
what traits are women attracted to
the classic male body type
um we talk about shoulder to waist ratio
a kind of v-shaped torso whether it's
broad shoulders there's a relatively
narrow waist that indicates like you
probably got some muscle and you're not
too too plump and you're capable of
doing stuff you're capable of
um running and hunting and fighting and
taking care of kids and doing all that
stuff
so the kind of like Olympic swimmer
physique
um
or the the MMA fighter physique you know
there's different varieties of this
basically having muscle not having too
much fat and being physically capable of
doing a wide variety of things that's
good
um and then in terms of psychological
traits
um I've spent like 30 years studying
this
um intelligence is important all those
Big Five personality traits are
important
um
sense of humor
which I've written quite a bit about
which is both an indicator of
intelligence right particularly verbal
intelligence but also it's an indicator
of social intelligence can you
understand other people's minds enough
to kind of tickle
their brains with a funny story
um and also a good sense of humor is a
good indicator of Mental Health
because people who have depression or a
schizophrenia or a severe autism tend
not to be very
funny in terms of like if they're trying
to make a joke it typically doesn't work
or they don't even bother making jokes
so if someone is reliably
um
funny particularly in one-on-one
interactions not just doing stand-up
comedy than
they're probably relatively mentally
healthy in terms of like not having the
major
uh mental disorders that are that are
big red flags
and do you think humor plays you think
humor is more of a factor I guess in
mate selection than height
I think they're both important I think
you know women
seem to have this this kind of heuristic
or rule of thumb that I I want a guy
who's at least as tall as me and
preferably at least a couple inches
taller than me so if you're a very short
woman that's that's pretty easy right
because there's about a three or four
inch difference on average between the
Sexes so if you're five foot tall as a
woman almost any man will do
um
I have some cousins uh female cousins
who are like six one six two if they're
looking for men who are even taller than
them
suddenly only one percent of men will do
and that's a very restricted
uh mating range so
yeah and I've talked a lot about this
with my uh 26 year old daughter also
who's in the dating Market in in New
York
um
and like one kind of rational strategy
you can do if you're a woman is
if particularly if you're tall if you
can kind of convince yourself to relax
this height standard
this height Obsession it really broadens
your your mating pool and then you can
focus on all these other traits that you
care about
but man if you go on Tinder and you say
okay I need somebody you know
um
at least six feet tall he's making at
least six figure income
a lot of men won't fit that who might
have made great
boyfriends or husbands
and so if you're just using like this
one Criterion to eliminate
eighty percent of men
I think that's pretty dumb
that seems fair I think that isn't that
one of the most common Search terms on
dating apps too is must be above six
feet yeah
yeah
and you know a lot of women aren't even
very well calibrated to like what is the
actual average I think in America the
the current male height average is about
um
but you know think about it objectively
like in the modern world is there
actually any difference in terms of
capability as a husband or father
between a guy who's five nine
versus six one
you know I'm I'm six foot zero so of
course I I'm a little higher than
average and I think Heights Heights good
Heights worked for me
um but if I was giving advice to young
women I'd be like
look try rationally to focus on like out
of the traits I think I want
which of which of them actually moderate
matter in the modern world versus which
are just kind of these evolutionary
vestiges
that really aren't as relevant as you
think
right
because the guy who's like five eight
who's in shape and confident and can
fight and knows how to protect you and
your kids is actually more useful
than some uh
you know six foot two lazy dude who's
never learned any sports or or can't do
anything physical
and where you're just getting into like
a height worship for no for no reason
I think
focusing on
mental stability
and humor those are two pretty good
traits and like an IQ but like you said
that kind of goes along mostly with
humor but those are the three that I'd
focus on stability
yeah humor and IQ and that can get you
so far and those are the those are some
of the key things you need if you're
actually raising a kid with somebody
right sense of humor probably correlates
pretty well with
um ability and willingness to play with
a kid
in a way that's kind of creative and
worry like you enjoy the kids company
and the stuff they do you find amusing
and you can amuse them and that's super
important
and you know the stresses of parenting
man you really need emotional uh
stability and resilience
because in a sense of humor if if some
guy who's single is already depressed
and anxious just wait till he's like
sleep deprived with a kid financially
stressed
feels torn between family duties and
career like
it doesn't get easier
right
so I think a lot of what women are
looking for is the sort of
unconsciously anticipating what traits
will be relevant once we settle down we
have kids we have a household together
what's what's going to be important to
me at that point
um what about what about for men do they
like similar traits or do things change
again I think men get a lot more choosy
about these mental traits in longer term
relationships and for deciding who do I
really want to settle down with
um
I think you know a lot of men myself
included tend to be attracted to certain
kinds of
instability in women when we're young
right like borderline personality
disorder can be extremely compelling and
enticing and attractive to men
um
but
that would make a terrible wife and mom
so what does that look like in a Wim in
a woman borderline is basically
um women who escalate romantic intimacy
very very quickly they would fall in
love very quickly they can be extremely
charismatic and
verbally fluent and and attractive to
man they can be sexually
perceptive so they'll actually Chase men
actively instead of just responding to
them
um but then once the relationship
develops
they'll be often very prone to anger
they'll alternately idealize the
boyfriend but sometimes demonize him
so they can switch from like you're the
best thing ever I love you more than
I've ever loved anybody
five minutes later they can be saying
you're the worst thing ever I hate you
you've ruined my life blah blah so
that's borderline Behavior
um and it
is kind of irresistible to a lot of guys
but once you learn oh no that that ends
very badly
then you know that's not actually going
to be a good uh wife and mother
so guys have to learn also to be
um
wary of that just like women have to
learn to be wary of the bad boys who are
kind of on the the psychopathy dimension
okay that makes sense
and then and then what were the other
traits the men are looking for in women
um yeah
I think cheerfulness goes a long way
Baseline happiness level like my wife
Diana is also an evolutionary
psychologist we've been together a
number of years she's just kind of
she's hyperthymic she's almost always
happy no matter what's happening she
enjoys life she is very emotionally
resilient
um almost never gets depressed
and that's a very important quality
um
when you're dealing with you know life
stressors like parenting and career and
moving houses and and so forth
um
so I think happiness and cheerfulness
are
my sense is that like gen Z doesn't
really advertise those things because in
a way you get more social credibility
than being neurotic and depressed
than from being happy and like being
happy isn't cool
um
but I think for attracting long-term
mate uh it actually goes a long way
because you know your your spouse's
happiness is going to determine
a large portion of your own happiness
over the the span of years and decades
yeah I think what's happening with Gen Z
is there's so many people that are um
mentally ill like there's such a high
percentage of the population is on some
sort of Psych Med or suffering from
depression or anxiety that
wow
I don't know how it turned into a good
thing really but I can understand how it
had to be less of a bad thing if so many
people are suffering yeah it's a weird
situation right now
and you know there's nothing wrong with
having depression anxiety being on meds
Etc I just worry that if you have a
dating situation that actually
incentivizes that
right that actively rewards it
um then you get potentially a lot a lot
of people who aren't really they're not
really temperamentally depressed but
they're kind of
um they're doing whatever gets rewarded
right and so if acting depressed or
talking about
mental illness gets positively rewarded
then you will see an increase in it
and and I think that can be quite
dangerous
that makes sense
um Jeffrey okay two more questions one
where can people go to find you and two
if you could recommend one of your books
that would help people I guess find a
mate which one would it be or or
understand themselves in order to find a
mate which one would it be
yeah um I've got a personal website
primalpali.com and on Twitter I'm
primalpali uh of my Twitter Persona note
is not my real persona it's kind of
performative and it's very politically
um
uppity
and uh Edge lordy
um if you're a young
single person I do recommend the book
mate that I wrote with Tucker Max which
is basically pure dating advice for how
to navigate the modern world
if you wanted for men and women yeah
actually a lot of the women a lot of the
people who've read it are women and they
say wow it it actually really helps me
to understand the male point of view and
the challenges that men are facing so I
can sort of navigate the The Mating
Market better
and if people want more of a like a
deeper scientific understanding of where
all this comes from than the mating mind
book from uh year 2000 I think is
good and I'm still very proud of it and
I still think it's about like at least
80 accurate scientifically
that's pretty good I will I'll link
those below thank you very much for
going on that was that was interesting
thanks good to talk to you take care
take care
[Music]